I go could you and Dante talk a little
to the the look of the film and how you
how you achieved it because the thing
that I love about it is this it's
stylish without being self-conscious
it's sort of effortlessly timelessly
beautiful and in in the new restoration
that you've done particularly I mean it
it plays absolutely off today I mean
it's it's very very restrained but
there's some extremely adventurous
techniques at play there that will very
ahead of their time I think it tells us
some of the the magic our shooting for
example in city lights and so forth sa
little thing before please it was the
memory I would like I don't know if this
movie needs to be any better or need it
to be any better what it is but I have
to say something provocative here from a
technical standpoint the movie is better
because of the transition to digital 4k
technology first of all because it has
been done extremely well but Michael and
Stefan Sun and feather company 3 but
because the total control on colors and
information on the shadows that now you
have or you don't the whole final scene
at the airport because you can make the
faces softer and bring the modes down
and reveal what's in the Far background
in a number of other situation it to me
makes the film better new technology I
think a very interesting thing that
happened here is the scene between Amy
Brenneman and Robert De Niro on the
terrace the calls for this ocean of
lights and in a very weird situation I
proposed to Michael that we take a look
at this new technology which is the
computer images put together with a
computer right and I went out shot some
tests and the ability of the shooting
the landscape is low frame rate so you
know raising the visibility even of the
clouds in the sky which are typical and
murky then marking those engines we have
lit from the orange light of the city
and then we shot the scene on the real
location just
in a small green screen behind the
actors so the shot from behind is a slow
framerate to raise the exposure good
catch it's all done with it's all done
with where we were in the real location
yeah with it you know up both for sunset
plasma and you're looking at the night
but you couldn't photograph it on film
you could in hi-def which is why the
great didn't in the collateral so to to
be able to see into the night the way
you could but we did is we put green
screens up blocking the actual view shot
the scene and then took the green
screens down and then shot the
background but at 3 frames per second so
get exposure right and so that's so as
beautiful anyway and Michael talked
about the locations a little bit because
it's an incredible epic and there's so
much scope it captures Los Angeles a
modern Los Angeles in a way that I think
no other film has to the extent there's
no nostalgia to it's a very clear view
of a modern Los Angeles I mean
extraordinarily you know begins with
someone arriving on a train which you
know it's not something you normally
associate with LA but it has this feel
of Los Angeles the whole way through as
a playground as a place to get lost in
as a sort of prison for these characters
so many different things the whole film
was shot on location you build any sets
did you build sets in two locations or
was it just take it as now I've never
met if there was a set I don't remember
which one was the whole thing we shot a
95 location so it's all it's my location
picture how many days four ninety five
location 107 Wow
so just moving who's counting
and I had a half hat I had and still
have the best location manager on the
planet Janice Pauly who's here someplace
boy a Vulcan and um but it began with
wanting to know Los Angeles and I
realized after having lived here about
ten or twelve years at that time or
extra 20 years that I didn't really know
LA at all we kind of we kind of moved
through a kind of a cultural
self-imposed ghetto of the places that
we go to in our industry and there's I
know that there's a lot more a lot more
out there so I started going out at
night with Tom Health Month who's also
here um who was a commander in LAPD and
we would go out of by 9 o'clock at night
on Friday and Saturday night just answer
random radio calls wherever they were
all over the city and we did this for
about five or six months and and that's
and we discovered the locations that are
there as well as as well as it's a lot
of dramatic content but then because
monitors are ready who's also here was
with me alone on all these various
adventures that we had the strangest
place we encountered is the Chop Shop
which was in an unincorporated part of
Wilmington that had and that was a it
was a pit bull fighting arena an illegal
abattoir and something else and that the
carro who's riding on horseback who came
through he is from that the guy who
owned it was a selvino guy who became
the doorman at PJ's PJs was a real place
for a while I think was in the basement
of a Payless Shoe Store or fluff LaBrea
it was the after-hours Club we didn't
shoot there with it so anyway it was a
real discovery of what los angeles
melissa anchez and i mean you're from
Chicago and the original inspiration for
the film was a Chicago incident you
never thought about doing in Chicago
somehow Los Angeles became I mean it's a
character in the film it seems like it's
the
the driving force behind the film is how
to capture that of an environment yes
you should for me la is more is more
transient there's more surreal it's more
balkanized in a great way and present so
many locations so I mean it really
becomes it's a dramatic choice it's not
it's all based on the same kind of scene
analysis that you know that I will work
with with an actor or they were that we
were doing any of our rehearsals the
same kind of scene analysis tells you
know it helps me trying to figure out
what you know what were that location
should be so it's not by accident that
bob is driving from having discovered
Trejo Danny Trejo and that betrayal and
gets the information to go after vans
Anthony's driving through that black
refineries which are like no diamonds in
the night you know it's kind of a
hellish landscape so you know you try to
you try to try to find try to find
places that speak and speak to you